-Our next guest
is a talented actress
you know from films
such as "Wind River,"
"Ingrid Goes West,"
and the Avengers
and Captain America franchises
She returns as Wanda Maximof
in Marvel's "WandaVision,"
which is currently streaming
on Disney+.
Let's take a look.
[ Loud banging ]
-[ Gasps ]
What was that?
[ Laughter ]
[ Music trills ]
[ Banging continues ]
-Wanda?
-Yes, dear.
-Are you using your powers
to turn on the light?
-Yes, dear.
-Allow me, sweetheart.
[ Crickets chirping ]
-What do you see?
-Only your lovely rose bushes.
-That's all?
Are you using your
night vision, Vision?
-I assure you, my love,
I see nothing amiss.
You have absolutely
no reason to be --
[ Banging ]
Aah!
[ Laughter ]
-You were saying?
-Please welcome back to
the show Elizabeth Olsen.
Hi, Lizzie! How are you?
-Hi! I'm -- I'm good.
How are you doing?
-I'm doing well.
You're joining us from London.
Hopefully it's not
too late there.
I mean, I know how late it is.
I understand time zones.
But hopefully it's not
past your bedtime.
-Um, no. It's fine.
I mean, I'm, like, properl
caffeinated, I think,
and have the shakes,
so I think I'm ready.
-[ Laughs ]
Now, I think a lot of people
living in the States
long for travel
and the idea of escaping
this sort of COVID existence
we're living here.
But London, sadly,
is no party either.
-No.
I was really excited
to come to London
'cause it sounded far more ope
than L.A. and New York wer
most of the year last year
And I got here the day befor
they announced
their second lockdown.
And then the world opened up
for three weeks here,
and we have been living
in a lockdown
since like mid-December,
and will be till March.
-Well, it is
outstanding wallpaper.
I will say that.
-Thank you.
I feel like my skin
is blending into it.
Like, I'm kind of worried
about this, like, weird ligh
that's on my face and...
I don't know.
-No. You look great.
It's a perfect match.
-Right.
-It's so nice when actor
and wallpaper can coexist
the way you are right now.
-Great. That was my goal.
It's a treasure map.
I'm in a children's room
in my rental.
-[ Laughs ]
So, this show is so very good.
I'm glad that we're talkin
after four episodes
because whenever you talk
to anyone
in a Marvel project like this,
you cannot talk ahead at all
And I feel like
after four episodes,
we at least have a better sens
of what this show is about
Has it been hard
doing press about...
I feel like
of the Marvel projects,
this one maybe has more secrec
and more twists behind it
as any.
-Yeah. It's really complicated
I want to talk about
all the sitcoms.
how it's like a sitcom,
but not just a sitcom.
And how do you tease that
and keep people interested
who want the action and then
get new people interested
in the sitcom part,
and hopefully you don't lose
them in the action.
So, yeah, but it's always fun.
I mean, it's fun to see
fan reactions.
I think that's what
I look forward to most.
-I mean this
with all sincerity --
One of the joys
of watching this show
is realizing that you
would have been a great acto
in literally every
generation of sitcoms.
[ Both laugh ]
Because you are so good
and authentic
in these styles from the '50
and '60s and '70s.
That must have been one of the
most fun parts of doing this
-It was. It was so --
I mean, I feel like
any actor has...
It feels like a gift when yo
get to do a period piece
or a genre piece.
And we got to do that
every single episode
and change what that was
and try and replicate
even, like, the lens,
the lighting, mannerisms.
The whole thing was just..
And then also getting to, like
nod to so many
beautiful sitcoms.
And then I had Kathryn Hah
by my side,
who is just the queen
of all things comedy.
And so, it was...
And then, obviously,
Paul Bettany
did such a great job
with all the physical comedy
and it was very Dick Van Dyke.
And it's been such a...
It was a really big joy,
and really, really hard,
but it was a lot of fun.
-You filmed the first --
This was, of course,
before COVID.
But you filmed the first
episode, I believe,
in front of a live
studio audience.
Was that -- I mean, I imagin
that's not something
that you had done before.
How was that?
-I've only done, you know,
theater before,
and then, like,
going on your show
or, like, other shows like it.
And I get way more nervous
for these kinds of things
than anything else.
I feel like I was really nervous
before with the sitcom
because it was our first tim
filming this show
and it was in front
of an audience.
So we're just, like,
filming our failure.
You know,
if it were going to fail,
it was gonna fail in front o
a bunch of people.
But then I get into a rhythm
'cause I know how to --
I feel like I know
how to do my job.
But this I don't know
how to do ever,
and, like, I have to do
breathing exercises
before, like, seeing
your friendly face.
[ Both laugh ]
-Do you -- So, are you
enjoying this era
of getting to do
sort of this press junket
without having to come
to an actual studio
where you have to do
breathing exercises?
-Yeah. You know, I don't know.
I feel like the trap door
usually freaks me out
before entering the stage
on night shows.
But I like seeing you in person,
and so it's a bit strange,
but I really don't miss
a junket.
You know, the four-minute cycl
for 12 hours of strangers is -
and some familiar faces, but..
That's nicer from home.
-You sort of mentioned
that this is a show
and, you know,
obviously, a universe
where there is a great amoun
of fan interaction with it
And I feel as though
with Easter eggs
and with characters from
different parts of this universe
showing up,
is that ever something
that you did with a show?
Where, you know, it would ai
and then you would sort of g
and read about it in that
sort of recappy fan service way?
-No. I'm, like, anti, like
looking at everything
on the internet,
generally speaking,
when it comes to something
I'm passionate about
'cause I don't want
anyone else's ideas.
I don't want spoilers.
I usually binge
"Game of Thrones"
after it's on air,
so I'm really good
at avoiding stuff.
And, yeah, so, no.
I also never cared about,
like, anything
that much as a child
to, like, seek out,
I don't know,
forums or something.
-The weird thing, and I thin
it really speaks to the fact
that I was probably a --
I was a child a lot longer ago
than you, but...
Like, I feel like I would've -
-[ Laughing ]
See, I also don't think
they had those.
-Yeah, right. I was like, "Oh,
yeah, why didn't I do that?"
Oh, right, 'cause it was, like
in the back of a comic book.
It wasn't like you
could go online.
You had to do a lot more work.
Was there a...
You know, you mentioned
that, like, those shows,
those old sitcoms, which, again,
like, you know, I wasn't -
I fortunately wasn't aroun
when those shows were airing
in the '50s and '60s.
But I feel like when I was
home sick from school,
I would watch them.
And I kind of underestimated
exactly how beautiful
and fun they were.
And I think that's one of th
sweetest things about this sho
is it is really an homage
to the way storytelling was done
in a sitcom form that far back
Did you feel, like,
how warm it was to do?
-Yeah.
And also, I mean, it was..
The family sitcom
throughout the eras,
I mean, even just like
"Three's Company,"
which isn't really
a family sitcom,
but the amount of joy you ge
from watching people
have a good time,
it's such -- it's such a fun..
I mean, I guess it's like
a form of empathy.
You have to enjoy
someone else's enjoyment.
But it really felt good.
And then the switch to other
elements of this show
felt so strange
because it felt so good to be --
to be a fool and to try
and make one another laugh
And also our director,
Matt Shakman,
just, like, oozes warmth
and friendliness and kindness.
And he had like three
different viruses
directing all these episodes
[ Laughs ]
I'm convinced he had COVID
in December.
He got so sick.
And he was -- he was
really like our leader
throughout all this
and directed the whole thing
with just so much warmth,
genuinely.
-It's really great. I also -
I went out of my way
not to even ask you anything
that you could spoil
because you have pointed out
in the past
that you're really bad
at keeping secrets.
So I hope I steered
far enough away from it
to not put you in
an awkward situation.
-I appreciate that, yeah.
I mean, I feel like I can
dig my own hole for myself
but, yes, I appreciate the help.
[ Both laugh ]
-It's always so lovely
to see you.
Stay safe over there,
and congrats on the show.
-Thank you.
-New episodes of "WandaVision"
are released on Fridays
and available on Disney+.